están robados Esa es la movilización de
los incondicionales el presidente Pedro
Castillo quienes desarrollan la
denominada marcha en defensa de la
voluntad popular y la democracia lo
manifestantes rechazan lo que califican
como el inicio de un golpe de estado de
la fiscalía y el congreso contra el
gobierno del presidente Pedro Castillo
ellos me han dicho que consideran que la
denuncia de la fiscal general Patricia
Benavides sería inconstitucional porque
vulneraría artículos de la constitución
peruana que permiten impulsar un ante
juicio por delitos de defunción y
señalan que delitos de organización
criminal la grabada tráfico de
influencias y colusión imputados por el
Ministerio Público contra el mandatario
según ellos no constituye un delito de
función y por tanto no se podría acusar
al gobernante durante su mandato Pero
para la fiscalía el parlamento y algunos
juristas los hechos sí califican para
procesar a Pedro Castillo Mientras tanto
la expectativa de los peruanos Se
incrementa porque este viernes El
Congreso de Perú revisa la de
constitucional de la fiscalía y en
paralelo algunos congresistas se alistan
una nueva moción de invitesment o
vacancia presidencial contra el
presidente Pedro Castillo